do you still identify as a black man the
one that hilarious do you still identify
yourself as one enough has changed you
know that that video you know more
people see me in airports or whatever
say you're that guy and I'm like what
are you talking about you you identified
as black I kind of have to
um let me finish the question yeah wait
wait wait young lady young you can tell
immediately to Father mode it was it was
great scene it's amazing this is
Northwestern University pretty highly
intellectual uh have you seen this no I
have not oh my God can you find one he's
explaining it he'll look for it go ahead
I'm a speaker with Young Americans
foundation so I go on college campuses
and the subject was the Iranian nuclear
agreement I love foreign policy national
security policy and so I I figure I did
pretty good I nailed this thing and so
they opened up a question to ask a young
lady comes up to me first question she
asked do you identify as black I was
just dumbfounded I'm like where does I'm
I mean we're talking about nuclear
agreements with Iran and I said yeah but
the the sad thing is that we have people
in America and and even in the black
community they think that your skin
color dictates how you think and and
that's one of the big problems that I
believe we have we have gone backwards
in race relations here in the United
States of America and this cultural
Marxism that we have been you know
permeated in our college and university
campuses now they're trying to push it
down to the K level uh we've got to
combat this I think that's the number
one issue that we have in the United
States you know a lot of people will say
uh uh uh what's going what's trending
right now is did you find it that's the
one the 27 second one if you just want
to click on that and and yeah I think we
you don't have Tick Tock okay got it if
you if you if you do the following it
just play this one it's fine even though
Rob
do you identify as black
no it's a serious question because you
might not identify can you please put
the mic thank you
okay
with my questions
I'm just asking you to listen to me and
I'm about to answer the first question I
didn't I didn't finish my question
okay
yeah I'm black
what do you think she was so angry about
that she wouldn't even let you answer
the question I mean well for those of us
that are not watching on YouTube and
just watching Spotify you are a black
man I can say that you know
download permanent tan yeah exactly yeah
grade 10. well yeah it is I've been
working on it for 62 years uh I think
the problem is that you know you've got
professors
telling these young kids that skin color
is supposed to identify people this is
the identity policy identity this is the
cultural Marxism that is out there and
the fear that these young people have is
that they don't want you to respond
because they are really afraid of you
totally embarrassing them with facts and
with knowledge and the other thing that
it shows is a lack of respect for elders
you know I've spoke at the University of
Buffalo I had to be escorted off the
campus of the University of Buffalo
because black students threatened to
hurt me now you know they probably would
have gotten a can of whoop ass open up
on them because I still have some skills
you know like Liam Neeson but the thing
is that here you had black students that
did not want to listen to what I think
is a decently accomplished you know
member of the black community because I
did not agree with their line that
America is a racist country and by the
way I think it's important to point out
for those of us that are just watching
not uh just on Spotify what have you she
was a black female it wasn't like she
was some white girl that was all getting
nuts over there how would you define uh
woke if you were to Define what woke
means what what does woke mean to you
woke means living in a delusion and and
a reverse reality of there's no
objective truth
that is it's all moral relativism is is
whatever situational ethics what have
you that works towards a certain end uh
and and I think that that's what we see
happening because none of this makes any
sense to stand up there and ask a person
do you identify as black first of all
what does Sam Hill does that mean and
and to to take the type of stance that
she took you know I remember when I was
a kid and I was sitting in the backseat
of the car and I had two aunts on either
side and they were talking to each other
and I interrupted them I got jab slapped
really quick I mean you know it was just
just how it happened with the backhand
and because I understood respect of our
elders we don't have respect of our
elders anymore and that's one of the
things that I saw when I was teaching
High School Deerfield Beach
every single day you're breaking up
fights you know why no one respects you
know that authority figure anymore and
so that's what I think this whole
wokeness does it breaks down the fabric
of of our culture and most importantly
the traditional nuclear family structure
you said race relations have gotten
worse in this country were and you said
you were born in a blacks only Hospital
in 1961 in Atlanta Georgia Atlanta
Georgia when did it when was it at its
peak worse and when was at its best you
know where have you seen it kind of uh
navigate over the last decade or two
well I I will be very honest I think
that the administration of Barack Obama
took uh race relations going in a
different direction uh when you have him
you know saying that the Cambridge
Police acted stupidly when you have Eric
Holder saying some of the things that he
said and here are here's the the quote
unquote first black president here's the
black attorney general and all of these
Great accomplishments but yet they
continue to say you know this is not
good enough you know and and you know to
now come up with this you know cultural
I mean this uh CRT and everything it
says that I'm sitting here next to Tom
and I'm looking over here at Adam you
guys are oppressors
how can that be and I'm I'm supposed to
be oppressed you know so we are going
backwards and we have taken Marxism
which was a socio-economic divisive uh
platform and we've taken it over to to
race uh and I will tell you that when I
grew up in my neighborhood the old
Fourth Ward neighborhood in Atlanta
Georgia that's where Dr Martin Luther
King Jr was born and raised Ebenezer
churches Baptist Church is there I saw
businesses I saw doctors offices lawyers
offices Auburn Avenue I I first uh the
black owned bank Citizens Trust Bank but
now when you go into our inner cities
what do you see
you see something completely different
you see the lack of small business
entrepreneurship and growth you see the
breakdown of the traditional nuclear
family when I was born the traditional
nuclear family and the black community
was 75 to 77 percent today is 24 and and
how did that happen when did this
dissent start Lyndon Johnson Great
Society programs you know war on poverty
which created poverty it created
dependency which is a tenet of socialism
creating the welfare and anti-state
economic dependency and all this type of
stuff by way of wealth redistribution
and so that's where I think it really
started to go in a different direction
with these these you know Great Society
programs and and look at what we have
happening look at look at the gang
violence and everything in these inner
city communities and that's all across
the United States of America so that's
what I think we have this dissent and we
really kicked it into overdrive coming
out of the Obama administration because
the progressive socialist left can only
Advance Itself by means of dividing us
and they have gone back to racial
division so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign